economía en france24 salud o en el
estudio de mi compañero jorge hurtado
jorge vamos a comenzar hablando de su
país después de estas elecciones
presidenciales en nicaragua esto cómo
afecta a la economía de esta nación
centroamericana bueno santiago la
permanencia de ortega en el poder podría
traer serias consecuencias en el plano
económico sobre todo vinculado con su
relación con grandes economías como eeuu
o la unión europea que no reconocen la
transparencia de los comicios de ayer
para darnos una idea de la incidencia
política en la economía nicaragüense
conversamos antes con marco aurelio
penya él es economista especialista en
desarrollo económico y esto nos dijo
durante tres años del
2018 al 2020 hubo una caída de menos
nueve puntos por ciento según datos
oficiales del marco central de nicaragua
por otra parte se es decir un montaña
negativa de crecimiento económico o de
crecimiento económico lo mismo también
el pib per cápita sufrió una caída y
ahorita el primer capital anda cerca de
los dos mil dólares creo que ha esperado
sólo pasa hubo una instrucción de más de
200 mil puestos de trabajo formales y el
incremento de la canasta básica ha sido
sostenido de manera que ya supera los 14
mil córdobas y se va acercando a los 15
mil córdobas para ponerte un ejemplo el
salario mínimo más alto por sector que
el del sector servicios apenas cubriría
o cubre seis de cada producto de los 53
productos de la canasta básica entonces
estamos hablando de que ha habido un
aumento
o un encarecimiento en el costo del
nivel de vida y por ahí ha habido una
pérdida por adquisitivo a pesar de que
la inflación se mantiene moderada
santiago y es que ya eeuu anunció nuevas
sanciones la administración de joe biden
estará revisando la participación de
nicaragua en un tratado de libre
comercio centroamericano nicaragua
exporta eeuu del 62% de sus productos se
importa un 30 por ciento de lo que
consume esto dijo nuestro invitado sobre
las consecuencias económicas de las
sanciones mientras no se resuelva la
crisis sociopolítica
entonces eso estará será un factor de
riesgo para una nueva contracción
económica que peligra se vuelva una
recesión económica de manera que la
economía a mi juicio marchara a medio
gas no habrá ninguna manera de pleno
empleo de las fuerzas productivas
principalmente por los riesgos de parte
del sector externo hablamos de una
comunidad internacional que está y
poniendo serias restricciones y eso
dificultaría el acceso al crédito de los
organismos financieros internacionales y
de organismos donantes porque recordemos
que nicaragua el crecimiento del
desarrollo económico ni grava
históricamente ya estamos momentos
depende del ahorro de trabajo y de los
recursos del sector interno jorge vamos
a cambiar de tema hablemos de las
acciones de tesla que calderón luego de
otro controversial tuit de y los mossos
así que se resintieron en la bolsa de
nueva york tras el revuelo en las redes
sociales de su fundador en los que
decidió vender un 10 por ciento de las
acciones de la compañía después de
proponer esa transacción en una encuesta
de usuarios de twitter veamos
es la persona más rica del mundo según
la revista forbes y quizás le sorprenda
saber que paga entre muy poco y nada de
impuestos en eeuu y lo más director
ejecutivo de la compañía de autos tesla
pregunté en twitter este fin de semana
si debería dar un paso que lo haría
someterse a un enorme pago fiscal en una
encuesta preguntó a sus más de 60
millones de seguidores si debería vender
el 10 por ciento de sus acciones en
tesla el 58% respondió con un
contundente si la transacción lo haría
ganar unos 21 mil millones de dólares
que estarían sometidos a los impuestos
para ganancias de capital probablemente
esta venta iba a tener lugar sin
importar lo que pasará más se enfrenta
ya a un pago de impuestos por las
opciones que tiene sobre acciones
valoradas en 15 mil millones de dólares
y ahora que el no ingreso salario o
primas su única manera de pagar
impuestos es a través de la venta de
acciones la agencia propublica publicó
unas filtraciones que demuestran que más
no pagó impuestos de renta en 2018 no
está solo el multimillonario jeff bezos
fundador de amazon no pagó nada entre
2007 y 2011
el presidente de eeuu joe biden ha
estado impulsando la creación de un
impuesto a los multimillonarios para
contribuir a la financiación del bild
back ver su plan de programas sociales y
ayudas el senador ron wyden quien
propuso este impuesto en el congreso
afirmó durante el fin de semana que el
hombre más rico del mundo pague
impuestos o no no debería depender de
los resultados de una encuesta de
twitter es momento del impuesto de renta
para los millonarios más que se
comprometió a cumplir con los resultados
de la encuesta dijo en twitter que
estaba preparado para aceptar cualquier
resultado esto de la economía siga con
nosotros buenas noches
[Música]